The jogan Experience what did you get
involved with this
season um well uh it ended with a
military coup in Africa where my team
and I got stuck mhm so that was part
ofca kickoff to all of it um it was in
ner so it's in the sahil region of
Africa the US has actually a military
presence remember a few years ago when
there were these four US Marines that
were killed in the SEL in Ni and nobody
even knew they were there there's
over a thousand troops stationed in nir
and uh we were there in a little town
called agadez which is in sort of the
Southern border of the Sahara Desert and
we were doing a story about gold mining
so the story itself was incredible we
had to you know we had uh monory Convoy
with us because it's incredibly
dangerous part of the world you've got
terrorism you've got Isis Al-Qaeda bah
Haram you've got kidnappers so it's very
very dangerous we'd gone there with the
permission of the government but only if
we we had to have a military Convoy with
us at all time so we're talking about
four armored trucks with lots of trained
soldiers that every time we stopped
they'd get out of the trucks and
basically Point their guns all around
they were very well trained a lot of
them are actually trained by the
American Military and uh we went out
into the desert and visited these gold
mines which are crazy it was an8 hour
off-roading into the desert to arrive at
these illegal unregulated mines we're
going down these tunnels and it's you
know 100 meters down hand uh dog tunnels
with no nothing to butress them no
safety precautions or anything but we
filmed it all and we get to the end and
there's people basically mining for gold
and and again constantly with the idea
that the military is telling us okay we
have to film fast we have to do this
fast we can't be out at night so we went
to a sort of safety uh more safe
location to sleep that night under the
stars and then the next day it's time to
come back to agades the town which is
about 100 miles but takes anywhere
between like 3 to 12 hours to get
because you can lots of things can
happen along the way and we arrived in
agadez and we got word that there had
been a military coup and the president
had been deposed and uh he was now being
kidnapped inside the presidential Palace
basically he was stuck there with his
family and that we were about to lose
our military compound and security and
they closed all the land borders and the
space and we were stuck and with no way
out because you can't travel by Road
without Security in that part of the
world and there were no planes leaving
so we were stuck wow how long are you
stuck for uh it was about 9 days uh the
military coup happened on a Wednesday
and we left on a Thursday sorry so eight
days but it was eight incredibly scary
days you know I'm I've been a journalist
covering black markets and going to war
zones and conflict areas all my life but
this was I think the most uncomfortable
and scared I've ever been because first
of all the uncertainty of not knowing
there were all these the West African
states were threatening Invasion the mer
the Vagner group the Russian mercenary
group were saying that they were going
to come and protect the new um military
cool leaders and so is a power struggle
between the United States and Russia and
that's sort of the last place he want to
be right and again no protection I'm
there with my team I'm sort of the um
the boss in that situation because I'm
the owner of the company that produces
this I'm the host of the show I'm the
executive producer and I felt very
responsible for my team as well and and
yeah the clock is ticking and they're
telling us that in a few days we're
going to invade and there's going to be
a massive POS possibility of a massive
war and we are stuck with again no
protection and no way out so it was
really really scary how did it get
resolved huh um that that's the
interesting part so the funny thing is
that the there was an American Military
Base actually one of the biggest Air
Force bases um ever built cost over
hundred million to build just two miles
from our little hotel in agadez we were
the only foreigners there apart from Aid
workers that sort of live behind barbed
wire and in compounds but we were the
only foreigners staying in a hotel this
hotel interestingly enough was actually
built when Gaddafi came to visit in the
'90s or late 80s and it was a rundown
hotel we were there again no protection
nothing and the military base is just 2
miles from us and we' tried uh to get
inside the base to film and we'd been
denied access to the base but when the
coup happened we managed to get a
contact inside and started asking them
we're here with no security can you guys
come and help us and figure out you know
take us into the base something where
all American citizens except for our fix
our local guy who's was actually from
Mali but everybody else was American and
they were stuck in the situation that
all the other countries had had started
calling this a coup but the US
government did not and because the
moment they called it a coup they would
have to remove um the military possibly
remove military remove their aid from
the country and that's the last thing
you want to do so they couldn't Evac
they didn't want to evacuate us they
didn't want to call it a CP they didn't
want to take get us out of there their
hands were sort of tied that's how they
told us and we started seeing slowly as
the day started passing and the
situation was deteriorating we started
seeing you know the French were take
were sending planes to take out all the
French Nationals the British the
Portuguese which is where I'm um a
double nationality where I'm from and
I'm on the phone with the Ambassador for
Portugal telling me there's a plane for
you there's like seats for you in the
capital but the capital is8 hours away
or 12 hours away by land and we can't go
because there's it's too dangerous and
no airplanes would take us there and
eventually we realized realized that the
only way that we'd be able to get out is
if we took matters into our own hands so
actually my team in La found an
evacuation company uh willing to fly a
plane in the middle of the night to get
us out that sounds like a Chuck Norris
movie oh it was evacuation company it
was actually Argo it was have you
watched the movie Argo with Affleck
about the guys I did watch that yeah and
how they don't know until the last
minute if they're going to leave or not
it was exactly that situation so we get
to the airport in the middle of the
night so they told us uh that we had to
be at the airport at this time that we
had to take security with us because the
pilot was refusing to land unless we had
security there
police um the police was supposed to
show up they never did we arrive at the
airport it's sunrise and uh the military
is there waiting for us yeah it's one of
those and they start creating all sorts
of problems saying we don't have the
right paperwork they're not going to let
us leave
meanwhile there's this amazing man local
man who worked at the airport that I'd
met a few days before when I went there
to try to see if there's any plane
leaving let us know and so I stayed in
touch with him and I had told him that
it was my son's
birthday um which was partially not true
it wasn't his birthday but he was about
to leave camp and I've got this
tradition as a working mother who
travels all the time we have this
tradition that I always pick him up from
camp and it's Performing Arts camp and
and so I told him sorry this is a very
long story no no it's
so I told him uh you know and so he was
there to help us but the military was
also there and they didn't want us to
leave and creating all sorts of problems
and then we see the plane land and we
see the pilot come out and we see the
military start walking towards the pilot
to tell them that we didn't have the
permission to leave and my fear was that
the pilot was immediately going to turn
around because he had told us that we
had 20 minutes he was going to spend 20
minutes on the ground and if we couldn't
get into the plane he's going to leave
without us and uh they get there and he
starts talking to them and I'm on the
phone with a team in LA and I'm freaking
out and telling them this is horrible
this is happening they don't want us to
leave and then my husband's on the phone
with me as well he's telling me I see
the Pilot's name and I think he's
Portuguese run to him and I ran to him
at the same time as a military and I
started speaking to him in Portuguese
and telling him the situation and that
do whatever you can to get us out and
the military can't understand Portuguese
so there was a secret communication
happening between me and him and and he
was Portuguese and he decided to take
the risk of getting us on the plane and
we managed to get out of it but the the
the guy from the military was still
yelling as the door closes but so was
the guy that I'd met at the airport who
turns to me yells my name and I look
back and he says Hey Mariana say happy
birthday to your son so in the midst of
the craziness it was also a beautiful
moment of connection and
Humanity